[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm
Jessica and today I'm
going to be talking about a
chemical demonstration called
the Briggs-Rauscher Reaction.
This reaction was discovered
by two San Francisco-area
high school chemistry
teachers, Briggs and Rauscher,
who were working
in a lab to come up
with a visually striking way
to demonstrate an oscillating
clock reaction,
Let's watch MIT's Dr. John
Dolhun show us the reaction.
Here he is at the
Cambridge Science Festival.
JOHN DOLHUN: OK.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to pour three colorless
solutions into this beaker.
Solution number one, and I'm
going to use kitchen chemistry,
so I'm using my eye here.
Let me just see.
OK, there we are.
Second solution.
And the third solution.
JESSICA HARROP:
So what happened?
Dr. Dolhun mixed three clear,
colorless solutions together.
The first solution
contains potassium
iodate and sulfuric
acid dissolved in water.
The second solution is malonic
acid and manganese sulfate
monohydrate in water.
And the third is hydrogen
peroxide in water.
And when mixed together,
things get complicated.
The overall reaction is this.
So iodate, hydrogen
peroxide, malonic acid
in the presence
of sulfuric acid,
reacts to produce this
compound-- oxygen and water.
But think about the
reaction this way.
It's equivalent to saying
that metal and plastic react
to produce a bicycle.
In reality, there
are many steps that
occur between those raw
materials and the finished
result.
And the Briggs-Rauscher
Reaction is similar.
Here are the many
subreactions that
occur to get from the
reactants to the products.
What we see is a
cycle from colorless
to amber to dark blue.
And as these reactions
run, the relative amounts
of the reactants
and the products
dictate the color
of the solution.
I2 is amber.
I minus is colorless.
And I3 minus is deep
blue when it interacts
with starch in the solution.
Triiodide is formed when
iodine and iodide interact.
And this cycle continues until
all the reactants are used up.
Hope you enjoyed the video
and I'll see you next time.